and tonight the FBI as we've been
discussing is in possession of a
document allegedly detailing a criminal
scheme from Biden's time as vice
president according to the claims in
what is known as an FD or 1023 document
Biden is accused of taking foreign
bribes in exchange for policy decisions
Comer believes these claims are credible
need to be investigated the FBI is
refusing to turn over the unclassified
document even after a subpoena the White
House is calling this a fact-free stunt
but if the document is not produced by
Thursday it won't be a stunt James Comer
is now promised he will hold the FBI
director in contempt of congress here
with more house oversight committee
chairman James Comer along with house
Judiciary Committee chairman Jim Jordan
let's talk a little bit he showed you
the document today you'd already seen a
congressman Comer
um but the question is my understanding
is the FBI has had this since what 2020
correct me if I'm wrong and and you want
to know if it's been investigated
right this particular document was dated
in 2020 but there are notes in the
document that date back to 2017. We
believe that this human Source initially
informed the FBI of the bribery screen
back in 2017. so my question to the FBI
was what exactly have you done with this
accusation because the FBI admitted that
this is a highly credible in fact one of
their most highly credible human sources
they admitted that they had paid this
Source a substantial amount of money and
he had been a part of the Bureau for 13
years dating back to the Obama
Administration and their answer to me
Sean was well it's now a part of an
ongoing investigation we don't know
which investigation we don't know when
the investigation began all we know is
two weeks ago they tried to act like
this form didn't exist and here we are
today with the FBI bringing the form to
the House of Representatives the Jim
Jordan let me bring you in here
according to news reports all over the
country today the arrest of Donald J
Trump is imminent maybe as early as this
week Thursday or Friday so we here
last Thursday you sent a letter to the
AG Merrick Garland demanding details
about the extent of FBI involvement in
the special counsel probe that is being
run by the special counsel Jack Smith
have you heard back
no we haven't Sean uh but but this the
bottom line is this never ends you go
back to 2016 when they use the dossier
that they knew was garbage to go spy on
President Trump's campaign then they got
2018 you got the whole Mueller
investigation in that election 2020 they
suppress the uh the hunter Biden laptop
story and then of course in 2022 91 days
before the election they raid president
Trump's home and now here we are heading
into the presidential election and you
got Joe Biden's justice department going
after their opponent the guy leading in
every single poll and that's after Alvin
Bragg has already indicted president
Trump and this Fanny this funny Willis
and George is probably going to do the
same thing so it never ends their quest
to go after president Trump and I would
just say this about the document Sean
this just isn't a document that's in the
possession of the FBI this is a document
they created and they created it based
on what Jamie Comer just said they had a
a credible Source one of their good
sources who they paid hundreds of
thousands of dollars bring this
information to them and then they create
this document we want to see it how much
you want to bet this source is a lot
more credible than Christopher Steele
the guy who created the dossier that
they used to go after president Trump I
bet you this Source has a lot more
credibility that but they will not let
us see this document I hope they do I
hope I mean the American people I hope
they let the American people see it and
Jim I would argue that I don't think I
think Ted Cruz is right I don't think
any indictment that comes this week is
going to have a thing to do about top
secret or classified documents because
then you have to apply the same standard
to Hillary and Joe Biden that brings Joe
Biden directly into that so it's going
to be okay obstruction of justice or or
whatever a crime about a non-crime if
you will because if they're not going to
indict on the original premise of the
investigation so but you obstructed the
investigation into the non-crime uh
allegation
yeah I think you're right I think there
will probably be an obstruction I think
Senator Cruz is right uh it's but but we
know this they've started they've
started out trying to get president
Trump in 2016. here we are eight years
later and nothing has changed it's all
been bologna it's all been bogus and I
think the American people see it for
what it is
James Comer let's talk about where your
committee is ultimately headed with your
investigation and okay and let's assume
that you hold director Ray in contempt
what does that mean as of Thursday
well we're setting an example when we
subpoena information there's a reason
why and we expect to get that
information the house oversight
committee was created to have oversight
over the federal government and what Ted
Cruz mentioned earlier and Jim Jordan
talks about all the time is we have
these Federal bureaucracies that think
they're immune to oversight so we're
following the money Sean I said this in
December when we announced investigation
we were going to follow the money and
obviously what we demonstrated a few
weeks ago when we showed proof that
there were many wire transfers from
Romanian National to the Biden family to
Shell companies that the Biden family
created that were then dispersed back
down to various Biden family members
these payments were made while Joe Biden
was vice president these payments were
made soon after just days after he flew
off flew out of Romania on Air Force two
at what The Whistleblower or what the
human format alleged in the FBI form is
exactly the same as what we saw in
Romania the vice president at the time
Joe Biden was in the country he was
talking about foreign policy and then
soon soon afterwards according to this
highly credible well-respected human
Source then there was a bridesmaid and
and it specifically detailed allegations
that the bribe would be made in a way
that would be very difficult to find
that they would use various bank
accounts in various shell companies wow
Jim Jordan the central question that I
think America is going to be asking by
the end of the week if all these all
these rumors of a pending arrest the
Donald Trump turn on to be true is is
the very heart of your investigation in
the Judiciary Committee and that is is
the FBI politicized and is the doj
weaponized is it have you gotten enough
evidence to convince you
yeah just look at the Durham report he
gives countless examples of how they had
no credible evidence no predicate no
probable cause they lost its
investigation in fact there was credible
intelligence that came into our
government that they put in the form of
a memo they gave that memo to Mr Comey
and Mr strzok Mr Comey Mr struck failed
to share that memorandum with key agents
working the crossfire hurricane case
working this case and when Mr Durham
interviewed one of those agents he
showed him the memo the guy read the the
memo became visibly upset became
emotional stepped out of the room came
back in and said I should have seen this
memo this could have changed what we
were doing in that investigation but
Comey kept it from him so yes there's
two standards and the people at the top
of the FBI know that was the case and
that is not supposed to be how it works
in our great country I agree with that
Jim Jordan thank you James Comer thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else